when i came to dubai
my world was very much centered around
the horse
when you're riding for a long distance i
think that you go through a big range of
human emotions my favorite moment is
when you feel that there is synergy that
the horse is working comfortably and
that you are becoming one
[Music]
my name is uma menthiya uranga i'm from
the basque country in the north of spain
i moved to dubai when i was 18 years old
so about 10 years ago i'm an endurance
horse rider at alarium endurance team
long distance racing consists of
covering a distance through open
landscapes so the races are about 120
kilometers 160.
there is a rhythm
of the horse that puts you in a
stage of concentration
and peace
in which you can feel that the space and
you are one as you travel as you wander
through it
there is something
powerful about being able to ride for
long periods of time for long distances
when i first came to dubai i came for
two weeks to just see the horses and
ride in the desert and i had met few
people that were training here
but i felt something strong i felt
something that would bring me back and
would keep me here
one of my favorite things was that i
could be in the library at 3 p.m and at
4 i was on a horse in the desert i think
that that's quite unique about this
place i think that it is a city of
contrast and that was something that i
found incredibly inspiring
i think the desert is a fascinating
place i've been
always mesmerized by its organic shapes
the fact that it's all sand it's colors
that change as the sun rises and sets
it's the landscape that has moved me the
most
you have your horse and
the landscape is yours to find your path
i think that that's
what makes me
love this place
[Music]
you